he's a pro football hall of famer love
his work on nbc football night in
america there's not one but two games
coming up this weekend the first one of
super wild card weekend raiders at
bengals and then the big sunday nighter
big ben and the steelers taking on
the kansas city chiefs joining us here
on the rich eisen show once again is
tony dungy how are you coach
hey ritz doing great good to be with you
you got it let's get just jump into last
week real quick before we get to this
weekend and the here and now
do you think that timeout so many people
making a a big deal of brandon staley's
time out
in that game do you think that did in
fact cause the raiders to kick a field
goal instead of taking the tie for both
of them do you think that no i i
absolutely don't i think rich versace
was going to do exactly what he did i
think he was going to run one more
running plate
run the clock down to two or three
seconds and try a long field goal if
they made it they win if they miss it
they tie and go to the playoffs so i
don't think it changed his strategy at
all now it may have given him a chance
to think about it better running play
and doing it differently
and but it also gave san diego
the charges los angeles charges a chance
to get their run defense squared away
and the end of the day was the run
defense of the charges let them down
down the stretch had they stopped any of
those runs early on in the drive it
would have been a tie game the amazing
thing is tony again you're a pro
football hall of fame head coach for a
reason
and there's so many permutations and
scenarios and possibilities when you are
a head coach in the nfl and being able
to handle it you know at a certain level
is how some
few select few like yourself get to go
inside of canton have you ever seen a
set of circumstances
like that
ever well that was that was difficult it
was different uh and it i think it did
impact rich versace's uh
strategy now number one you want to make
the playoffs so he had the score tied he
knew he was in
but he also knew this
if we tie this game we're going to
kansas city we've lost to kansas city
a couple of times by big scores uh if we
win this game not only do we go to
cincinnati but we've got a higher seed
so if crazy things happen
uh we we have a chance to play a lower
seated team at home so i think he did
what exactly what the circumstances
dictated make sure you don't lose make
sure we stay in the playoffs but we want
to win this game tony dungy here on the
rich eisen show and now it's the
steelers
against the chiefs um what's your
assessment of this game uh knowing
tomlin as you do do you think he's
playing the nobody believes in us house
money card to the hill oh absolutely and
it reminds me rich so much of 2005
uh we had a great team in indianapolis
we played the steelers in december and
beat them 26-7 it wasn't a close game we
dominated excuse me all passes to that
game
and
miraculously pittsburgh comes around
they win a couple of games at the end
they beat cincinnati when carson palmer
gets hurt they come back to us nobody's
giving them a chance same scenario same
stadium playing us again they totally
outplayed us in the playoff game and so
i i think that you know ben
roethlisberger was there he's going to
build on that mike tomlin knows that and
yes
the great thing is we'll make some
adjustments
what kind of adjustments will they make
they certainly have to think they're
going to beat us kansas city has to
think that we're going to use that to
our advantage so i i think it's going to
be a great game did you ever
ask tony dungy did you ever ask nick
harper why he cut back allowing ben to
tackle him did you ever have that
conversation
yes now we always we practice those
situations we practice staying on the
sideline using your blockers outrunning
people i know
nick if he had to do it again he would
stay outside he had he got injured
uh before the game uh two a day before
the game hurt his knee and i think he
really thought he couldn't outrun
ben robertsburger and that's why he
broke it back and nine 99 times out of a
hundred he would have stayed straight up
that sideline outrun roethlisberger and
we probably would have won the game
i'm sure you don't like talking about it
but i appreciate you doing but before
that i'll tell you that another story
rich yeah we got stopped on fourth down
at like our 10 yard line everybody
thinks the game's over i told gary
brackett
the only chance we've got now gary we've
got to cause a fumble gary brackett went
out there and put his helmet on the ball
on jerome bettis and knocked the ball
though
and i'm thinking when that ball came
loose i'm thinking
we're going to win this game gary did
just what we needed to do um yeah it was
it was a crazy crazy crazy game and of
course you got a uh yeah you got back in
the game with a we challenged an
interception by troy palamalu that was i
promise you a hundred out of a hundred
it's an interception but it was that
calvin johnson hit the ground troy
caught it rolled over got up and
celebrated and dropped the ball and they
said he didn't complete the catch and so
if we hadn't won the game i would have
felt bad about it because we benefited
from a challenge that i didn't really
believe pro football hall of famer and
nbc sports tony dungy joining me here on
the rich eisen show which team
which road team let's throw the niners
out unless you want to throw them in
there go ahead which road team do you
think has the best opportunity to to
shock everybody and come up with it i
really think three road teams are going
to win this week out of six i don't know
which they are we've seen so much up and
down this this field is wide open of
course you could see easily see new
england going to buffalo you guys talked
about the weather report hey maybe it's
a cold game again if buffalo can't throw
uh that really hurts them and it
benefits new england san francisco i
think has the ideal situation they've
got a power running team
dallas is a great fast defense they fly
around they force turnovers but can they
hold up if they pound the ball and run
straight at them and
nick bosa already said we think we can
generate a pass rush on these guys we
think we can come after that prescott so
that one i think is going to be good the
raiders are our saturday game on nbc the
raiders that first game was a lot closer
than people think raiders had the ball
going in in the fourth quarter with a
chance to make it very very interesting
and they throw an interception it ends
up being a blowout but that game was a
one score game for for 55 minutes so uh
i i think every team every visiting team
i think has a chance even the eagles uh
the eagles i would give maybe the least
chance because i think tom brady is
going to be surgical against that pass
defense but um
i think every
road team has a chance what is the
challenge though coaching
against a team that you've already seen
twice though you know i mean we got that
monday nighter you got so much in that
regard so the challenge i think the team
that loses really has the advantage
because you are forced to make changes
you do things differently if you won
that earlier game or two earlier games
you say why should i change that would
look dumb what i did work so you kind of
have a tendency to sit there and do what
you did the other team
makes some little tweaks and they have a
little bit of advantage i think so um i
never like to play a team in the
playoffs that you already beat in the
regular season tony dungy pro football
hall of fame coach right here on the
rich eisen show i know there's so much
that goes into it ownership uh whether
you like the general manager who is
there or
you need to be hired by a gm you've
never met or you are a coach who
obviously has the the ability to say i
want this person at my side for
personnel
uh is there a quarterback already there
or so on and so forth but which current
opening in in the nfl do you think is
the most attractive
well you have to look at jacksonville
because you've got that franchise
quarterback uh trevor lawrence everybody
in the draft thought he is ready to go
he's legitimately there so that that's
sitting there and this kind of reminds
me of
the dallas cowboys of the late 80s where
they drafted troy aikman then they had a
bad year jimmy's first year they win one
game and now you've got another draft
class that comes in with that franchise
quarterback so i would love if i were in
it i would love to go to jacksonville
say my quarterback's there now i'm
drafting to fill some needs i've got
some young talent already there in three
years we could be dynamic
and of course you you go to the place
where they don't require you to fly home
with a team right is that what you're
doing
yeah that's another benefit
i mean it's just been a wild year
certainly
you know on that reference i made to
urban meyer and then the surprises i
mean brian flores fired in in miami and
then i don't i kind of thought david
colley did everything that was asked of
him what did you make of those two
firings tony dungy here's what i make of
it and i could be wrong brian flores it
obviously wasn't about record they're
getting better they're winning games
they're they had a seven game winning
streak this year so it's not about
uh
performance something else was going on
there and i don't know what that is
but then i think that spurred step two
uh the gm
at houston is familiar with brian forage
he's got a new england way of doing
things and all of a sudden this coach
that i didn't think was available is now
available uh that leads me to make
this decision on on david culley i can
get a guy who's a good coach from a
system that i know who i've worked with
and we can work together i would be
shocked if brian flores isn't in houston
uh in two weeks okay so uh right now as
you and i are talking though there's
only one uh man of color who's in a
position of hc and it's mike tomlin
um what adjective do you use to describe
this alarming
[Music]
concerning disappointing or transitory
what do you want to what what word would
you use
tony it's really been an up and down
situation and now we're in a down cycle
and i'm going to put the head on the nfl
uh we're hearing these names mentioned
and you you hear brian flores he's going
to be mentioned and you're hearing jim
caldwell and leslie frazier and todd
bowles and byron leftwich and we've
heard eric the enemy for a long time
we've got six openings now let's see
what happened and if we end up with just
one african-american coach at the end of
this cycle then it is going to you're
going to have to say wait a minute this
isn't a coincidence hmm so what it what
what is it tony what i mean what to what
do you owe it the nfl is it's a crazy
business and it's 32 people making their
own individual decisions
and
i'm not sure why brian flores isn't uh
still a head coach in miami i can tell
you it doesn't have anything to do with
race it doesn't make sense you you
aren't firing brian flores because he's
black you hired him
and he's winning he's starting to
deliver for you so something else is
going on now there are some other places
where i think yes african-american
coaches have gotten overlooked because
people
they aren't looking for them they've got
jacksonville is a great example i
promise you last year urban meyer was
the guy they were going to after it
doesn't matter who they interviewed who
was good
urban meyer was their guy well there is
some of that
and you know at one time that was me i
was jim irsay's guy
and when i got fired he was gonna hire
me uh it so happened i was black so that
that was one in the african-american
coach's
uh column but he was going to hire me no
matter what and that that happens and
that that's okay but we've got to get
the league as a whole we've got to get
everybody to look at all these
candidates and make good decisions don't
just focus in on a guy and say that's
our guy evaluate everybody find the best
candidates do what
dan rooney did
15 years ago with mike tomlin
search explorer dan rooney had four guys
on the staff at that time who were going
to be tremendous head coaches ken
wisenhaut dick lebeau bruce aryan russ
grimm and he said i i could pick one of
these guys and nobody could complain
about it but you know what i'm going to
go out and look i've got a formula i
like young
defensive coaches that can be
with me for 15 years so that's what i'm
going to look for and he ended up
finding mike tomlin and that's what
we've got to encourage these owners to
do get your blueprint and then go out
and look don't just hire the biggest
name or the first person that comes to
mind go search
and how many times does your phone ring
anybody still kicking the tires to see
you believe it or not i have talked to a
couple of people and believe it or not
my wife hung that phone up
in like the past week or so or like yeah
look at her yes sir
your wife hung the phone up is that
because is that because she doesn't
she made me hang it up okay
because because why she knows that if
you if you hear it out what you're you
might actually entertain is that what
you're saying well no and i probably
wouldn't uh i'm 66 years old i've been
out of the game 12 years and there are
some there are a lot of great coaches
out here that will be able to do the job
for years to come and i think that's
what people should be looking for
tony dungy before i let you go you're uh
who did you say before the season was
going to make the super bowl what was
your preseason prediction you know i i
said the same thing that i'm saying now
i don't know i always
bet against the the team that won it
last year because i think it's so hard
to repeat but i just do not see a team
that's playing consistent football that
i would say you know those guys are
going to go um i i would if we see four
road teams win this week and see four
upsets it wouldn't surprise me at all
well and then then it benefits a team
that's not playing this weekend like the
packers you don't think they're playing
consistent enough football rogers and
adams look like they're on a different
planet like they're connected
and and the run game and they're getting
healthier on defense you know like you
don't you don't look at them and say
they're the team to be they are but i
saw a loss to minnesota by then that
that surprised me and you know i've seen
tennessee play
and win these games but i saw them in a
three-point game at houston last week
with the number one seed on the line so
um i i just
i think those two definitely have an
edge because they only have to win two
games to get there but i i would not
make them prohibitive favorites well
tony uh i love talking to you thanks for
the insight i'm also um
honored i'll say it this way honored
that uh when i called your wife didn't
take the phone and hang it up so
i'll take that as a copy she knows rich
eisen on the caller
okay i'm just that i'm i'm so i'm
relieved too that didn't happen so
thanks for the call tony
thank you rich great to talk to you yeah
you bet have a great weekend of
broadcast that's tony dungy
you got two calls
yeah man
yolo i'm going yolo on him i'm going
yolo on tower i'm going yo low
oh yeah
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here